the Traveling Salesman is a famous
mathematical problem it's a it's a huge
problem actually and it's very very
relevant not just for salesmen the kind
of are the kind of topics mathematical
topics subject areas that it's under um
you can classify it a couple of ways you
can call this an optimization problem
and you'll see why in a second and it
also fits under a particular kind of
branch of maths called graph theory now
by the way can I just say it's called
graph theory but it almost has nothing
to do with what you think of when you
think of graphs okay and I'll explain a
little more in fact we're gonna draw
some graphs on here and I say okay so
let me give the travel you settle to the
problem to you in a nutshell okay these
dots that you've got here okay they are
locations like cities for example okay
and there is a Salesman let's put them
over here there's a Salesman yes it is
compulsory for the salesman there okay
this is Ellis and he wants to visit yeah
he's traveling I suppose I'll give him
I'll give my suitcase depends what kind
of Stan Smith is right
his task is to visit travel to all the
cities but because he's salesman he's
trying to be cheap and efficient it was
to travel to all the cities in the
fastest time or the lowest distance
possible so this problem in other
regions of the world is called the
ancient salesman okay he wants to get to
all the points as quickly as possible
now you may remember we had a look at
our other problems which have this kind
of graph theory we need to visit certain
different places that bit of a problem
okay so we're gonna dig into that a bit
more deeply but here's what I want you
to do okay you've got either two or four
copies of this set of CDs okay what I
want you to do is independently when
your own and with the ruler would be
helpful and if you've got one
unfortunately
few hit me with a ruler be helpful
because obviously if for instance I want
to go from here to here clearly the
fastest path from one to the other is a
straight line okay so I mean you can
draw a decent straight line probably
freehand but if you have a ruler it'll
be even better we're going to be
measuring these things okay so I want
you to and you can start wherever you
like by the way I've just happened to
start him up there I want a bit you can
start anywhere you like the only
condition is you need to travel to all
the cities and you want to minimize
distance right so like it it
independently start any way you like and
see how efficiently you can do it now
just give it a shot
don't worry about trying to rework it
and rework it you will but on separate
pieces of um the map which is why I give
you so many copies okay so give you a
few minutes try it out and then measure
out the distance in millimeters off you
go I'm going to show you some strategies
for solving this problem it's a great
little problem um the question was given
to me because there are a formula for
this is there a formula and the answer
is no there is not which is why all of
the methods I'm about to show you it's
why they exist in the first place by the
way I did say this just informally but
this problem right of a Salesman the
actual problem the reason why this is
like legit mathematically significant is
that this is exactly what data does a
farm we replace our traveling salesman
with like okay right and then there's
you know you're on your laptop computer
your computer there I'm just going to
get rid of it in a second you know
because save yourself American you're
done right I cannot physically go
directly Frode you to Google because
there is not just one wire one really
really long wire cable joining you to
their servers in fact you have to
communicate with well it'll be your
local exchange there's like a depending
on what kind of incident you used then
that's going to communicate so like
whatever
Telstra TPG or what
oh yeah for God's like from you to your
router then to your exchange then to
your ISP they told me call the arm these
are cool mobile there's a coastal set of
stations basically that send pipes
underneath the ocean it gets to the US
and then once it gets the US it's gonna
do the same journey in Reverse till it
gets to Google now there are hundreds
and thousands and millions of different
paths that can be taken right that we
just haven't drawn in okay
so this problem this optimizing for the
shortest path right is actually a
enormous mathematical significance okay
so let's think about this now the method
that you did just now okay and I think I
believe the lowest number we bought was
277 they do a beat to 77276 one a peak
we gotta careful we have to be careful
because that's correct
there's a we do you remember little bits
of accuracy you've got you've got rulers
and they're only so active right so I
think we're gonna call to 76 to 77 equal
winners I don't know you but the park I
took this was the first part that I drew
okay
it was basically it was basically
guesswork like I just kind of looked at
what it looked like and I tried to
intuitively guess out of pong okay now I
was asked a very clever question before
which is actually very insightful the
question was do we have to return back
to where we started
now the answer is no because you have to
you just have to visit all the cities
that's all you have to do but but
actually drawing out the whole thing and
joining it back up actually will help
you reduce your answer how to think
about this right I've now closed off my
loop okay so I have a complete pot back
to the beginning right now the part that
I didn't have before was this one here I
started here and I ended here but being
that I don't have to return to the
beginning I can't remove any one of
these paths any one I like because I
don't have to start and end at the same
spot so for instance
when I choose a park like this to get
rid of and the answer is no because I
don't have much to gain by getting with
it this one it looks to be on my part
that yours might be different I guess
he's gonna be one of these right one of
these looks like it's the longest yeah
Benetton so you can see by getting rid
of this guy I have now actually shaved
something off of my pond I had imagined
it because anyway but you get the idea
so maybe you want to scrutinize your
answer a little bit more and see if you
can reduce it just by changing your
starting point